[Music]
welcome back so we're talking about how
we can use the singular value
decomposition to compute a least squares
regression fit for data okay so a linear
regression best fit linear regression
model given some data a that should
correlate to some output B okay and we
walked through a MATLAB example of a
simple linear system with one input and
one output now we're going to look at
some real world data that have multiple
input factors a and some output output
factor B again all of the code is that
data book EUCOM in both matlab and
python here we're going to walk through
the MATLAB examples okay and so there's
two examples we're gonna look at the
first one this is a built-in data set in
MATLAB called the Portland cement data
set so you load hauled okay and what
hold has what this data set has is
essentially it has a set of ingredients
these are kind of multiple ingredients a
that your cement mixture could be made
out of and be the output is how much
heat was generated in the process of
mixing and mixing that cement so as you
mix up cement and it cures it generates
heat and so they measured the heat
generation given all of these different
mixtures of cement and so what we're
gonna do is we're gonna load this data
and we're gonna say that the input
factors if I want to have an I want to
build a model potentially for given a
mixture of ingredients what would be the
heat generated by those ingredients so
we're going to to load this data we're
going to compute the SVD of a and get
our best fit slope essentially of the
heat as a function so there will be a
plane that fits heat as a function of
ingredients in a best fit sense and
that's given by this slope X and then
we're going to plot it okay so this
one's pretty simple I just want to show
you what it looks like so this is the
data so there are 13 different kind of
mixtures of ingredients and actually I
should probably show you I believe there
are so I don't know if you can see in
the upper right
this a matrix let's let's just run the
size of a so the size of a is a 13 by 4
matrix so what that means is that they
did 13 experiments there are four
ingredients you could mix up so if I
just take a these are the the 13
experiments and those are the mixtures
of ingredient 1 2 3 & 4 so essentially
we have a four dimensional vector a or
four columns of that matrix a if you
like and each row is a different
experiment where they mixed up that
mixture of ingredients and then computed
the heat for that mixture of ingredients
and so on and so forth and so when we
plot this essentially what we're seeing
is across all of those 13 experiments
we're seeing the heat generation I'm
assuming you know maybe this is in
temperature I don't know what the actual
units are and then what we're seeing is
the actual data in white and the
regression model in blue so you can see
that from this data you can build a
model that pretty faithfully captures
the variations and the different
mixtures across across this data now
this is I'm being a little naive here in
reality you wouldn't use all 13
experiments to build the model and then
plot all 13 because that might be
overfitting I might be kind of
overfitting the slope of X to this data
and then if I had a fourteenth
experiment it might be totally different
so in reality what I might do is I might
randomly pull ten experiments at a time
build a slope X pull another 10
experiments at a time build a slope X
and either average over those slopes or
use the remainings or three experiments
to see how accurate that slope was on
holdout data that I didn't use to train
the model now that's what we'll talk
about that much later and in much more
detail how to validate your statistical
models and not over fit by by plotting
it on top of the training data like I've
done here but it's just a simple
illustration ok another data set that I
think is really fun is the Boston
housing data again this is a built in
one in MATLAB you just load housing and
then there are a few different variables
that get loaded so you have
in this this vector B that I'm gonna
generate from from the data T is the the
price of the houses in thousands of
dollars and this must be a pretty old
data set because these are like 50,000
40,000 dollar homes and I don't think
you can buy a home in Boston for 50 or
$40,000 now ok so B is kind of the
output and a are all the factors that
might factor into a home price and I
don't know what these exact factors are
it would probably be things like you
know density of houses per square
kilometer or proximity to an elementary
school or you know proximity to a
freeway things like that that would
affect the home values so there's a
bunch of factors in P that I'm gonna
rewrite into a matrix a and I'm gonna do
something else else I'm actually adding
in a column of one so this a matrix has
all of these factors that people think
are important and if I only built a
regression model on that a the slope
would necessarily the the line would go
through the origin so there would be
some values where the home price would
be zero or even negative and that's kind
of fishy in my opinion so what I'm gonna
do is I'm going to add a column of ones
here to my a matrix another column of
one's let's just do that right now so I
have my column of ones so that
essentially what that gives me is a
constant offset it gives me so I have a
slope and it's gonna allow me to fit an
intercept kind of the the offset of this
distribution because you can't buy a
house for zero dollars maybe the kind of
minimum or average home prices I don't
know at this time twenty or thirty
thousand dollars so that's what this
column is going to allow us to do okay
good now again there's a lot of ways of
computing this here I chose to use the
regress command you could absolutely
compute the SVD and do pseudo inverse
and that's totally fine you could do P
inverse I'm just gonna plot what you
have here okay and I'm gonna plot two
things what I'm gonna plot is the true
house value and the predicted house
value given our model a times X just for
all of the houses and I'm not going to
sort them or order them or do anything
fancy here in the first subplots
then what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna plot
that exact same data sorted by home
price okay so I want to point out here
that these really are tools for
analyzing your data you don't just want
to compute the SVD for the sake of
computing it you want to build these
linear regression models so that you can
understand the factors that drive the
outcome that that's what a model is and
in fact I mean that really is the basis
of all of machine learning so you have
this kind of new energy and machine
learning and building models from data
but really we've been doing this for
hundreds of years with these regression
models okay so this is what the data
looks like let's see if I can reshape it
a little bit make a little flatter ok so
again it's it's a little hard to see
because there's so many homes there's
five hundred homes these are their
prices
I must have subtracted out actually no
only the blue values dip below zero the
white values are all positive home
values so these are in white or all the
actual home values for the 500 homes and
in blue are my model predictions it's
actually pretty darn good they're not
perfect there's some blue values that
are kind of silly right you can't have a
negative home value but when I plot them
in a sorted way when I sort these these
these values by the home income so I'm
sorting everything by the value of the
the true white dots here then what you
see is that our model prediction in blue
is actually doing a very very good job
of capturing this trend there is
statistical variation there are you know
there's variation from home to home in
the in the thousands of dollars but the
general trend is is captured by this
regression model you know I don't know
what the what the dominant factors are
maybe it's you know proximity to a
school or density of you know people per
kilometer or something like that who
knows how many shops are around depends
on what those factors are but to some
extent we are capturing the right
distribution of this model okay now
again I'm kind of cheating here because
I'm using all of the data to train my
model and then I'm
the model on all of that data so I could
absolutely be overfitting to to the data
here okay good
what you can also do is you can look at
what that vector X those slopes actually
look like and what you can do is you can
see which which slopes X were the most
informative informative in building this
prediction model so here we have kind of
the actual magnitudes of the slopes
across each of these 13 factors so again
if I go back to the size of my data and
I say size of a I have 506 by 14 factors
okay so I've got 506 home values and
each of those home values we measure 14
factors that we're gonna try to
correlate to those home values and if I
plot here I think I've removed the ones
column this is how these are the actual
slopes or the loadings of each each of
those factors each of those 13 factors
this should factor into the home price
and so you can see that some of these
are more important than others like
factor 10 is a really really positively
correlated with home value so if you
have more a factor 10 your home value
goes up
maybe that's maxima tea to a school or
something if you have these factors 7 &
8 are anti-correlated with home price so
if you have more of 7 or 8 your home
price will actually be lower maybe
that's something else that it's not
desirable in a home ok so that's kind of
interesting you can actually interpret
these slopes of your model again we're
gonna talk about this a lot more in a
lot more detail in in later sections and
in later chapters of this book okay how
to validate these models how to get more
interpretable models using l1 penalized
regressions and the lasso we'll talk
about that in chapter 3 how to cross
validate and make sure you're doing your
statistics and your machine learning
right we'll talk about that in chapters
four five and six but there is something
I want to I want to point out so I do
have to show you how to hold out data
for testing because you can't just build
a model on all of your data
say it looks good and used that model
you have to have some data to test it or
validate your model on so what we're
gonna do here is out of my 506 homes
where I have data right 506 I'm gonna
take the first 253 of them and I'm gonna
train the model on that 253 and then I'm
gonna test the model on the next 253 and
we're gonna see how accurate those those
models are so it's exactly the same
thing except now I split my data into a
training a and B and a test a and B and
I'm gonna plot these here okay let me
just make this a little bigger so the
top row shows the actual home values I
should probably put legends on this let
me just legend to this real quick the
legend is true and model open up model
and true okay okay that's not good
colors okay good so red is the model B
is blue is true here and so what we see
is that in the training data I remember
I split my data into half that I use for
training and half that I use for testing
in the training data we're actually
capturing the trends really really well
it matches almost perfectly because
again that's how I built X was so that
this matched really well when I apply it
to my holdout data that I didn't use to
build my model you see that for some
homes it actually does a great job but
there are other homes where it
completely misses the factors that
correlate into those home prices okay so
this is a little worrisome that the data
only works sometimes and not others the
mod will only work sometimes and not
others on this testing data okay and I
would actually see like as a modeler
when I see something like this what this
tells me is that the time series kind of
the the index of you know home one
versus home two versus home three
sampling was not random they may be
sampled one neighborhood than another
neighborhood than another neighborhood
and we just don't have any data of this
neighborhood in this model okay so that
might be why that's doing such a poor
job and so we might be able to fix this
by instead of just picking the first
half to train on and the second half to
test if I randomly shuffle all of my
data and then take the first half of the
second half I have a very high
likelihood of sampling all of these
neighborhoods to build my model okay and
that's what we're gonna do next and so
if I use this R and perm command here to
shuffle all of my data so I get a vector
of different indices and I shuffle the B
and the a matrices with the same random
permutations and I run this code what
you'll see is in principle this model is
doing a lot better job on all of the the
test set so it's not it's actually less
good on the training data there's
there's more variability of the model on
the training data potentially but it's
doing a more faithful job of capturing
these kind of trends in the testing data
okay so really important for us to
recognize that a couple of things let's
recap if you have data of a bunch of
input factors let's say these 13 factors
that might factor into home price and
you have a truth measurement of what
that home actually costed costs or was
sold at then you can build a regression
model you can find kind of the slope of
this hyperplane that best fits that data
that best correlates those input factors
to that output that you want to that you
want to be able to predict in the future
so if you want to predict future home
price you just measure these these 13
variables you multiply it by X and you
can get a decent prediction of your home
price but again you have to be super
careful when you build your models you
can't use all of the data to train and
to test that's cheating so you have to
hold some of the data out for validation
and you have to be careful about how you
sample your data so that you don't get
biases for one neighborhood versus the
other okay thank you